hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
kth smallest element in a binary search
tree
so we're given the root of a binary
search tree and an integer
k and we want to return the kth smallest
element in the binary search tree right
and so remember a binary search tree by
definition means that it's in
order meaning that for let's say 3
everything in its left subtree is going
to be
less than 3. everything that's right sub
tree is going to be
greater than three and so let's say k
equals
one that means we want the one smallest
element
in the binary search tree so if you put
all four of these elements in order we
get a one
two three and four the smallest element
is
one so then we can return one and now so
your first
thought with this problem might be that
okay so
in order like you saw what i just did
right i just took every element and put
it in
order and then took the kth element
right and if k was 2 we would get the
second element if k was 3
we'd get the third element right so is
there a way i can take this binary
search tree
and then put it into a sorted array or
something
and the answer is yes right because
binary search
tree means that if we traverse this tree
in order and then take each element and
then put it into an array
then we've basically solved this problem
so for example we start at the root but
we don't
visit the value yet right we go to the
left child right and then we see okay it
doesn't have
a left subtree right doesn't have any
left child so then we visit one
by that i mean we basically put it
inside of our array
then we go to its right subtree we see
okay two
we add two to the array and of course
since we know
k is one we could actually stop here
once we visited the one
but we could also continue to add
elements so then we'd pop back
up to the three add the three and then
we go to the right child and then
see the four and add the four and so you
know
that writing an in-order traversal for a
binary search tree recursively is pretty
easy right but
i'm going to show you how to do it
iteratively which you might not
know yet but it's actually pretty
similar to doing
the recursive solution so you saw how
the recursive solution works right let's
say we visit one
then we go to its right child right we
visit one and then we visit two and then
we end up having to
pop back up to the three right
so to pop back up here we know the
recursive call will eventually
come back like with the call stack right
that's how function calls or method
calls
work but if we're doing it iteratively
not recursively right
then we need a stack to contain
the previous nodes that we need to pop
back up to
so i'm going to show you how to do this
problem with a stack iteratively
so let's say that this is our stack
so iteratively we start at the root
right
and we we're not going to visit this
node yet right
so we're not going to count it as a k
value yet because we want to go through
everything in the left sub tree first so
next i'm just going to keep going as far
left as i can so i'm going to go to this
node right
it's left child but before i go here i'm
going to add the 3 to the stack
because we know we want to pop back up
to this 3 when we're done
traversing the left subtree so now i'm
at the one i'm going to go to
its left child right but we see it's
null
right but before i go to null i'm going
to add one
to the stack but once we reach a null
case
that means it's time for us to pop back
up and go back up to the previous node
and we know that because we just look at
the top of our stack so we take this one
we remove the 1 and so basically when we
remove an element from the stack that
means we're processing it or
visiting it and we see k is equal to
1 this is the first value that we just
visited right
so then it must be the result so the one
that we just popped
is going to be the output right but
let's say
that it wasn't let's just continue the
iterative solution just so you can kind
of understand how it
works so now i'm at the one right
we just process the one we don't have to
ever consider it again so i'm just going
to cross it out
but now once we pop up right we visit a
node
then we want to go to its right child
only after we
visit the node after that do we want to
go to its right subtree right because
remember we're trying to do this
in order so
with three still remaining in the stack
we're gonna go to two right so now we're
gonna
add two to the stack and now i'm gonna
go to the left child of two right we
know it's
null so so then we're allowed to pop
back
up right so we're gonna go to the two
it's because it's at the top of our
stack
right so the 2 is at the top of our
stack so now we're going to pop the two
off
so meaning we're processing the node 2
or visiting it so we can cross it out
now
and now i'm going to go to its right
subtree which is
also now null right because now that we
process two we're allowed to go to its
right subtree but we see that it's
null so since it's null that means we
pop
again from our stack right so we're done
with this null but
conveniently for us we have a three at
the top of our stack we crossed these
two values out
so now we're going to automatically go
back up here
so we pop the three so now it's time to
process the three right we process it we
look at it we visit it whatever you want
to call it
and after we visit it then we were
allowed to go to the right
subtree so now we we're at four so we
add
four to our stack and you basically know
what's gonna happen now we're gonna try
to go to the left sub tree but it's
going to be null
so we pop from the from the stack so we
process
four but then we try going to the right
subtree it's also
null so now that so now we look at our
stack right we're going to pop again
from our stack but our stack is
empty right so that's how you know the
algorithm is done we visited
every node that we needed to and if you
were actually keeping track
and you noticed the order that we popped
the elements in
so basically the first element we popped
from our stack was a one if you were
paying attention
after that we did a two right we popped
the two
and then we went back up to the three we
popped the three
and then finally we visited the four
right so even though we did it
iteratively we visited the elements
exactly
in order so it's surprisingly the
iterative solution
is not quite as hard as you might expect
let me show you the code for it now
so i'm going to declare a variable n
to basically tell us the number of
elements that we visited from our tree
once
n equals k that's how you know we
visited
the element that we wanted to and then
we can return that value
and remember i'm also going to have a
stack which is going to help us
because we we need it because we're
doing this iteratively
so i'm also going to have actually a
pointer cur
it's going to initially point at the
root it's basically going to tell us
what node that we're currently visiting
or at the node that we're currently at
and so i'm going to have a while loop
basically while current is not null and
the stack is non-empty we're going to
continue
traversing our binary tree right that
makes sense so far
and remember the first thing we want to
do is let's say we're at ker what are we
going to do
while current is not null we're just
going to keep
going left right remember we want to go
through every node in the left sub tree
before we visit the current node so
while current is not null we're going to
set current equal to current dot left
but remember before we do that we have
to go back
up to current after we're done
processing current dot
left so before i do that i'm going to
take
the stack and add current
to it and so when this loop is done
executing that means current is at
null so that means we went too far and
that means we have to pop
the last element that we added to our
stack so actually stack
pop we're popping the most recently
added value from our stack
and we're going to set it to cur so now
that we popped this element
curve that means we're processing it so
what we can do is actually
update our n value that means n
that means we just visited another node
so we can increment n
by 1. and if n happens to be equal
to k that means the current node that we
just
processed is the value we're looking for
because remember we are
looking for the kth smallest element
so if that's true then we can just
return
current.value and we're done we don't
have to visit any extra elements
but what happens if this is not the case
well
we just processed current right that
means
that we're allowed to now go to its
right subtree so we can actually
update current now and set it to current
dot
right and so what's gonna happen now
well the loop is gonna actually go back
up if current dot write is non-null or
the stack is not null then we're gonna
start our loop and for that node we're
gonna keep going left as much as we can
maybe it doesn't have a left
sub tree so then this part isn't is not
gonna execute and then we'll end up
we're gonna end up just popping again
from our stack
and conveniently for us in this problem
we're guaranteed to have at least k
nodes in our tree so this
is actually always going to execute
we're not going to end up
exiting this while loop so we actually
don't even need a return statement over
here
and this actually is the entire code let
me just run it for you to prove that it
works
and as you can see it's according to
this not pretty efficient but i'm pretty
sure if i ran it again i would get a
much more efficient time but you can see
this is the
iterative solution it's roughly this the
same time complexity as
the uh recursive solution and
surprisingly
uh it's not that much code right like
you might expect the iterative solution
to be more complex
but we're actually not doing anything
fancy we're just going as far
left as we possibly can adding the
values to the stack
and then popping from the right when we
need to
so i hope this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon